ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata si sa che uno
dei dolci più famosi in italia il
tiramisù che allo stesso tempo è uno dei
dolci che la maggior parte delle persone
discesa per fare benissimo poi gli
assaggi e fanno ora siccome il tiramisù
è quel dolce che teoricamente riesce a
tutti quanti mi sono detto perché non
fare una sfida in cucina e provare a
fare un tiramisù senza poter toccare con
le mani
nessuno degli ingredienti che vuol dire
che potrà utilizzare cucchiaini forbici
le stesse confezioni l'importante è che
non sono a contatto con l'ingrediente ma
soprattutto per i passaggi più
complicati titina la dinosauro avrò lui
che è il mio assistente in realtà quello
che farò alla fine una specie di t rex
nice
direi che possiamo partire è inutile
pure che ve lo dica per fare il tiramisù
servono uova caffè cacao in polvere
savoiardi o non iniziamo con noce metti
i pavesini no ci mette i biscotti
a me questa voi hardy cioè preferisco
con altre cose però volevo farlo
tradizionale e di base cioè non è che
faccia schifo e cementi sale presenti
savoiardi mascarpone è un sacco di
caffettiere per fare il caffè
quindi a questo punto viene ripartire
con la sfida allora ho aperto il caffè
non l'ho toccato il problema ne sapete
qual è che non so fare il caffè il male
per quanto riguarda il caffè
ok infiliamo a ma io non ho manco una
bilancia quindi oggi si fa occhio e
ripensiamo le prime tre caffettiere una
due o dio
lei 3 andrà man 3
divertiamoci ad aspettare era uscita
tutti 4 cioè sempre in realtà
mamma mia e uno qui non si può un attimo
rilassare 1 vabbè dai due caffè questo
ancora deve uscire poi stoppato tutto
capito ci stavamo fino in fiamme davvero
curci nella mani ma li mettiamo tutto in
ordine
abbiamo tanto da qui qui buono ma se la
mossa di aver portato tutti quanti la
caffettiera da casa è stata la migliore
è non bisogna mai avere una cucina
sporca specialmente per arrivare il
padrone di casa altro giro altra corsa
123 andiamo con un altro non posso
toccare un po su creazioni so nemmeno se
si faccia così il caffè qual è il metodo
giusto per fare il caffè caffè tv come
fai a capire quando il caffè fa schifo e
quando buono c'è il mio so che fa schifo
e adesso è arrivato il momento di fare
la crema di aiuto io sì sembra un
momento magico
ok è stata cenni guscio molle le uova
bravo ti mangiano
nel frattempo qui stiamo creando il
panico
basta ragazze pieno all'orlo oddio
ragazzi un problema faccio 2 uova intere
e una metto solo il tuorlo capirai
io devo prendere solamente il tonno ti
volevo toccarlo con toccato devo
prendere solamente il tuorlo capitolo
faccio scolare la rotto il rotto vero è
se condannato andiamo così perché adesso
è comunque più tuorlo capito sì sì sì sì
sì
passiamo allo zucchero che sarebbero
tipo un 130 grammi
la lalla stop
secondo le sue 0
no non solo ti dirò tu puoi sbatterlo un
fatto che è un po un trucco in ogni cosa
nella vita
secondo me può andare
aggiungiamo il mascarpone che grazie al
cielo già pesato perché ci servono 500
grammi di mascarpone esistono per il
tiramisù al devo toccare niente io non
sto toccando niente non ce la fa ok va
bene ha fatto tipo l'effetto che non
abbia lo stesso sapore
ora userò un'altra tecnica si chiama la
tecnica giotto tutto attorno come un
cerchio in modo che poi con le stesse
forbici grey's anatomy togli tutto
quanto
grazie
torniamo nella mia seconda cucina
ok facciamo un piccolo una piccola
analisi più caro ragazzi prendiamo i
savoiardi ho bisogno dell'aiuto di
titina cercavano il muso ha fatto così
tanto e offrire cioè che sono solo a
respirare questa genera svegli per un
mese allora 12 ma non ho le sue zanne
diventano terribili dei savoiardi veloce
veloce sentina di essere veloce e
dinamico perso ho perso titina salvano
mamma mia non è sto di remi sul viene
così new motion mollo che oddio no no di
viva degli estremi brand non ti buttare
giù di tina avevano un altro agguerrita
agguerrita pickin up ma veramente quale
la tecnica migliore per inzuppare
savoiardi cioè tipo deve essere a
temperatura ambiente deve fare 12 capito
cioè presente che c'è chi conta che
misura la temperatura del caffè aretina
noti tina noti tina titina le perso
titina questo qua è veramente disgustoso
questo periodo fuori
ok tac tac veloce
ecco questo
insomma massa lo gira dall'altra parte
continuava niente questo pezzo è
difficile ma una partitina perché devi
inzuppare inzuppare dividere brava
mangiano mangerò bravissima col colpo
del feroce predatore
tu non hai capito io potrei essere un
tirannosauro e poter avere una testa di
tirannosauro al posto di questa mano ne
sono reso conto
insomma è un po troppo capito titina
pulirsi giu chiedo perdono tutti quelle
persone che sanno farlo il tiramisù io
perdonate un dinosauro non ci riesco ok
ok ma scusatemi è vero l'ho toccato l'ho
toccato la polka titina sacco il tuo ben
muso in quell acqua salmastra dopo
possiamo bruciarla questo qui non è un
tiramisù con questa è una zuppa direi di
spolverarlo subito con un po di cacao
[Musica]
questo è il mio t rex miss un po so
dirlo un fallimento totale
questo con la cannuccia si prende
piccoli e troppo
no integra la cosa migliore ora e
metterlo in frigo anni e pregare dei
vostri ragazzi questa sfida finisce qui
fatemi sapere se anche per la colle rete
e proverete anche per cucinare un
tiramisù con un t rex e quindi creare un
bellissimo tir ex miss se avete dei
consigli per chi non sa fare il tiramisù
tipo ma credo l'unica persona italia a
non saperlo fare o almeno ad ammettere
di non saperlo fare fatemelo sapere con
delle foto dei messaggi su instagram qua
sotto
io vi abbraccio e adesso pulirò tutta
questa quindi che dire ci vediamo la
prossima settimana sempre alle 12
ciao